[Music]
fear to me means absolutely nothing
anymore fear played such a big piece of
my life and it controlled me to not do
what was best for me so fear to me now
is nothing but an imagination
[Music]
my name is flip Rodriguez I'm a
Hollywood stuntman and on American Ninja
Warrior in the ages of 9 to 15 I was
sexually abused by my father like how do
I live my life after that like I can't
trust anybody I got into parkour and
freerunning when I was at age of 19
parkour and freerunning are two
different definitions are very similar
parkour is just straight forward
vaulting jumping over walls over any
obstacle in your way rerunning is - your
own style your own flippin flow of it
make it nice and pretty as possible and
you take your time when I first got
started I've never been upside down so
my body's like wait whoa we don't do
that and then the fear aspect hits in so
it's like let's stop and think about
this is this really worth getting hurt
[Music]
fear is what stopped me from trying to
stop my sexual abuse parkour freerunning
has been a stepping stone for me to heal
and be okay with my sexual abuse it's
because fear is a big part of parkour
and freerunning so every day I trained I
was always encountering a new fear I
started in America Ninja Warrior season
3 and then on season 7 actually
explained my story I was sexually abused
after my interview came out I've had
kids write to me one of the parents
reached out to me turns out that the
daughter and the son were being sexually
abused by a family friend the child sure
started breaking down crying she was
like what flip is talking about is also
happy to me
and they brought up charges the
gentleman got convicted of that and that
right there blew my mind away because
not only did I heal myself but I also
saved somebody from further abuse and
that was incredible I like to give back
to the community with using my story I
coach Parkman free running I'm not
teaching him just about parkour
freerunning
I try to teach them tools of life you
guys just saw we kind of fell a little
bit what do you got to say
[Music]
every single person can relate to fear
yeah so if I can teach these kids from a
young age to separate fear from danger
that is a life tool my negative piece of
my life I can now turn it around and put
a spotlight on it in the sense of this
is who I am this is what happened to me
and look at me I'm still shining my
ultimate goal is just to have my name up
there with my dad's name when they're
picking some of the best drivers in the
industry to work on a big car show you
know I don't want to be the best woman
driver the best black woman driver I
want to be the best driver and one of
the best drivers don't get too cocky
because denying of the other work
[Music]
my name is Brianna Lynch I'm 21 years
old and I've been a stunt driver for
four and a half years my name is Julie
Oh J Lynch I'm her dad
and I've been in the business for 27
years all the dangerous stuff that the
cars are doing in the movies all the
exciting stuff we do that and not the
actors so a couple of the films that
I've worked on our Black Panther Proud
Mary Fast and Furious 8 Beyonce's music
video formation and creepy and that's me
and my dad right there I got started in
the business to a New Jack city I've
done all the Fast & Furious series since
number four and Jumanji and I'm one of
the guys up there on the bike yep that's
me right there so cool because I am the
cool this fly over when my dad and I are
working together we actually like to
help each other set the cards up so when
I have to do something like sliding
around the corner my dad is right there
with me trying to make sure that
everything is set up so I think that's
what makes my dad and I really unique
[Applause]
I got in the stunt driving because of my
dad they taught me how to ride when I
was 3 years old and he's been teaching
me in my entire life he's so good at
what he does and so respected in this
industry so since I started son driving
he has been my motivator and my coach my
teacher he's everything but my
accountant
pretty much
one of the things that I had learned by
riding with her all the time was that
she was able to handle the pressure 3 2
1 action as much as people don't believe
that you're inside a car when they
explode people are in those vehicles so
it's a lot to let your kid go and be in
danger I guess part of being a parent
and part of being in the stunt business
we do as much as we can to keep her as
safe as possible and then after that you
wish for the best
I love that I get to share a
stunt-driving with my dad I think that's
a really cool bond that the two of us
have my dad not always been very close
he's very supportive of me chasing down
this dream that I have and if you want
to be good at something you have to put
the time in it's important for you to
enjoy your life and actually love what
you're doing that's the biggest picture
[Music]
good morning my name is rocky Tyler I've
been a stunt man for 54 years as I
started around 1961 yes I'm the hottest
working stunt man I suppose I was the
youngest
now I'm the oldest
[Music]
your source fell into it I should fall
about and do what the actors couldn't do
ie get punched for over a chair dives
and rolled along the ground my first
stunt job was a film called the young
ones with Sir Cliff Richards
they gave me a Guinness record I've got
it over there the oldest still working
stuntmen in England the only stuntman to
double for two bombs in one year Roger
Moore the name is gone and Sean Connery
[Music]
my last film was this Sunday I was
working on a little car chase sequence
around - Fargo square which was great I
mean I've been in it for so many years
now and I can't think of anything else I
can do
[Music]
I had a very bad action on deaf we
straight I need to go guilt this is the
this shot of me doing the fall which
nearly took my life when they blew it
out before I got to the edge I'll run
through the flames put my hands up over
my eyes came through broke my back
pelvis
thank God I survived I don't know how I
survived but you're gonna get a little
knock and a little proof that's part of
the job
why do I keep doing it I've had a great
life I've been around the world twice
I've met all the stars
I love it ladies laughing else about it
[Music]
[Music]
bananana coaster at the relevant wash
kitchen
I always grew up with a passion for
cause and especially iced tea
when you're in the car the wildest
places you doing what you love and you
forget about all your other
[Music]
I'm Kaylen I'm 17 years old and one of
the top female spinners in South Africa
spinning is the fastest-growing x3
motorsport in South Africa spinning
started off as illegal because people
stole cars and Spanish as a sign of
celebration it became legal now because
we do it or at a controlled thing
competitions not normally charged by a
panel of judges they set out the track
and they ask you to complete it in the
one who does it without touching the
comb or pumping the tyres
[Music]
[Music]
my father was the one will boarded the
car and then got me into the spinning
[Applause]
micro special to me because it's
modified to my advantage like the sink
is higher because I'm very tiny we
basically freeze them most of the time
we took the back wheels burning so that
it's always smoking until the type of
have to be able to control a carburetor
yeah
they are a handful of female Spanish but
I wish there was more it's great to be
one of the few women in the sport it
just shows that you have the ability to
do anything you put your mind to I
[Music]
definitely see myself as a role model
not to just women but to guys as well
because as mini-date asked me to teach
them how to spend they want to be like
me someday in the spinning culture we
more of a family like them and anything
goes wrong mostly not always came to
Europe on another
[Music]
spelling has taught me a lot like a
testicle to be confident myself it has
taught me that or whether you make
mistakes it doesn't matter just carry on
driving you will get through it's all
worth it because it's my passion
[Music]
you